oh my name
welcome back Misha
Gary Dyke we unpack and why does every
episode always start like that these
days
okay two episodes it's one Episode two
Manny he is right there isn't he
how did he see me when I all [ __ ] mouths
it's you and me buddy
I'm a sure I'm a [ __ ] chair don't
look at him all right
he's exiting he never leaves mouth he
never leaves now I follow you might have
a panic everything I don't trust you I'm
sorry don't worry baby Joey you can try
this how do I know miles good fuzz
follow you through that all right oh
there is being finished
Kyle thank you for that in town all
right so he opens the door what are you
making noise that making noise it's
right
[Music]
oh my god did not see me
Oh J says did you see that man Asha I
know I was amazing we can't go in here
he needs to break that door I think so
we'll just have to wait I guess I don't
think my body will be able to take
another four all right we could always
try I mean you got to be enthusiastic
right flame my dozen flames talk to me I
don't understand that
all right now he's got a oh he's just
chilling in the door that's what I
usually the [ __ ] the life of a bro
man is chilling in doorways struttin
that ass man
come on sauce oh all right it is
supposed to go here [ __ ] cheated
really loves chillin indoors uh-uh
come on don't die if he can't come here
I'd rather jump down there
well like it no it's impossible
let's go and break the door man do your
[ __ ] job
where is he all right I think he left
gonna crouch now all right yeah you know
thank God
all right so he was hitting something
oh there's not even a door here oh the
keys too hot to carry what about this
key I flip it over I blow this week ah
shove it I don't trust you anymore shava
people help me
that doesn't work
Javed what do you write tell without
gotcha don't break dance in front of me
shower it's not gonna persuade to me um
ain't no break guys are like a peopie
break and then I'll [ __ ] well what the
[ __ ] am I supposed to make a cosy mood
what was the point of this room I don't
get it
all right we came from here
yes that's correct
it's snowing in the end nice fight
snowing flight what the [ __ ] man
gust Amanda why did he go then I'm
serious I'm super carry to the left to
the left this game is [ __ ] difficult
as hell to the left I'm circling like a
bar fall too hot alright I get it I get
it it's a puzzle we can do this
bruh bruh you will come to use
I love the bro infinim ready you're like
why the [ __ ] do they give you a broom
how do I know that just drink sir what
was he hitting in here is he hitting on
the new shovel No
come on Matt scrape that [ __ ] off it
what am I supposed to do in here
I don't [ __ ] know hoe that is a SOHO
around me like a bow oh because I like
mom just like I like my opinion that was
really inappropriate I'm sorry I'm
really sorry
what about ya oh I know I flip this over
in the world falls down that is how it
is the way I flip you over the wall is
going down you just go down this is how
it may be I bring one of these they're
too heavy so many ideas oh oh oh I see
it outside before you side wait you've
been screaming in the mic for hours but
the video is only a couple minutes house
don't be mean man don't be mean
there's supposed to be something here
yeah there's a door here and it's
[ __ ] to see it come on
[ __ ] do the limit push it through
the penis and just squeeze through all
right now against creasing here we are
that torch could come in handy in dark
places right barrel
oh sorry but you're flat oh no this is
the third about the barrel
don't step you can't have it mine
whoa what what what what what what if
George doesn't like me
oh-oh I got a hold it alright alright
you see this [ __ ] barrel wow this is
awesome
come on cut whoa what's going on down
there let's drop you torchy and let's
check it a binky huh
alright well I guess that's a way down
but it's going on in here
Oh legs and stuff
oh no all right
that's a burning torch nice [ __ ] [ __ ]
that and that's the closet I'm not going
in a we need to find something to
against the fire I have fire hey I'm
getting really good oh there it is water
now does not get these two mixed up
there you are touching now let's go team
I mean go go to be it do you have one
all right I like Itachi I cared about it
you are so bright and nice man let's go
get the key open the door female mentor
progress yawn
Sanyasi sewn the audio oh I % you hey
this mod isn't really really well made
glide was really good I love it sapphire
alright let's go to this place it's a
bit torchy aren't you what my ad jumping
George a turkey Hey but there you are oh
look what torch a girl my wheel ages wow
I bet it weighted charge ago hurry up
stop Barry too much
having two fun with the place out ow all
right Archie don't you come here a there
we go let's go change you go first pin
it all right all right
I'm scared bang Wow dad people burning
that sounds like after all
I get the feeling piggies Plus just get
that idea
alright let's go here I go yeah down
this little thing my best it's gonna
need a key but that's okay not gonna
need a key
I taught you that's guy oh we're down
here now
alright cool I'll go in here all right
Archie all right I don't have to drop
you down me all the townie
say that Georgie hit something
torchy are you trying to tell me
something No
all right they really I don't really
feel like loading all of these all the
time you see there's probably nothing in
there or you getting like a tinderbox
how does someone commented about it and
be like Barry you gotta check all the
things they're like no I don't really
have to that is torchy don't be sad I
still love you bear down out of here you
just want flash lighting that was my
skype me stop crying in a little bit all
right we're not going in there then
let's go and hear them double
flashlights power so no one feels
actually no let's just use it for cheese
it's more awesome all right this is
exact summarize I had before where all
this stuff scattered on plate okay well
why do we need the hammer it's probably
baited question put about my hand my
hand something else torchy what are you
doing
torch it what the [ __ ] man all right
let's keep solving Panos check it out
barrels you see what I got I told you
don't talk to them right now you squeal
man thanks great oh thank god you
[ __ ] [ __ ] try to steal torchy from
me all right I bet this is gonna come in
handy
all right what's going on in that door
there
oh wait use the hammer on that [ __ ] stop
all right there we go there we go torch
it what the [ __ ] torchy not funny
no oh wait maybe yes thank God thank you
Mosley what's going on down there yeah
hey [ __ ] period I know that that tastes
like wow this is a hard month to stop
playing I get the feeling I run out of
time but I didn't you play all right I
just keep going it hey nice penis man I
recognize that dick and naked
I don't know don't come here with your
penis that's really awkward
it was dangling a lot like hypnotizing
all right are we supposed to find like
we got to find something in that room I
mean if my friend came in like that I
was like oh here we go Aiki Internet hey
John you are wondering where the wine
cellar is the thing is listen with the
guests we had to tighten the security
down there I want to write down the
details here but I can tell you that the
kids starting in storage Section C hope
you will find it let's go there next
episode all right so like a favor if you
enjoyed it subscribe to come bread today
and I'll see you next time don't make
sound somebody I'm that guy
not am i back to nine yeah [ __ ] yeah on
the bar